The Nightmare on Elm Street series is one of
horror's most enduring franchises. Throughout the
series, a whole lot has changed about this dream
demon. But some things stay the same in the town
of Springwood, Ohio. Here are some things that
happen in every Nightmare on Elm Street movie.
Freddy leaves a trail of destruction wherever he
goes, but no matter how many people he slaughters,
he can never seem to kill that Final Girl.
The main hero of the Nightmare on Elm Street
movies always gets away. Even when it looked
like he killed Nancy in the original film,
she showed up in Dream Warriors very much alive.
Granted, the Final Girl always has a
tough time. She barely out-maneuvers
Freddy throughout the story while
he hacks and slashes her friends.
And in the end, just when it seems like Freddy
is about to add the Final Girl to his score,
she pulls the rug out from under our big burned
boy, and Freddy’s the one who ends up dead.
Of course, sometimes, the Final Girl in one movie
becomes a "regular girl" in a subsequent movie.
At that point, all bets are off, and Freddy
may very well shuffle her off this mortal coil.
And we should also point out that not all Final
Girls are actually girls. In Freddy's Revenge,
that role falls to Jesse Walsh, who's
technically a Final Boy. Granted,
his fate is left somewhat ambiguous at the
end of the film, but we never see him die,
and if Nancy survived her bizarro dream
ending, we're sure Jesse is probably fine.
Freddy always attacks his victims in
their dreams. His victims occasionally
figure out how to pull him into
the real world, but Freddy begins
stalking potential human pincushions in the
astral plane before it gets to that point.
That's also one of the main reasons why
Freddy makes such an unsettling figure.
Everyone has to sleep, and if Freddy attacks
in dreams where he has absolute power,
then Freddy can kill anyone at
any time, any way he wants to.
Ergo, every Nightmare on Elm Street film
contains scenes of characters drinking coffee,
munching down caffeine pills, blasting
loud music directly into their earholes,
and engaging in various other activities
designed to avoid or delay sleep.
It's a futile effort — but the cannon fodder
kids in Nightmare movies all have to try.
Oddly enough, the Freddy movies depict
relationships between teenagers and their
adult guardians reasonably accurately. As anyone
who remembers being a teenager knows, whenever
teens find themselves trapped in life-or-death
battles against demonic forces, they immediately
learn that parents, teachers, and professional
mental health experts are all completely useless.
Making matters worse, grownups typically insist
the kids are simply stressed out and need a nap.
These so-called "responsible" people always claim
the unholy menace doesn't exist when, in fact,
some of them personally helped burn him alive
after the judge let him off on a technicality.
Nancy's dad provides an exception
that proves the rule in Nightmare 3:
Dream Warriors when he tries to come through for
the gang at the Westin Hills Psychiatric Center.
Even then, he was a major skeptic in
the first film, and he only decides to
be useful after he develops alcoholism due to
Freddy killing Nancy's mom. In the real world,
if a grownup happens to be chronically
depressed and constantly drunk,
that grownup will be about as effective against
supernatural malevolence as a bag of potatoes.
For slasher fans, there's a sadistic glee in
witnessing homicidal mayhem that would traumatize
us all into a coma if we saw it happen in real
life. This is extra true for Nightmare devotees
because Freddy kills any way he feels like
killing, even if it defies the laws of physics.
Johnny Depp made his big-screen debut as
Nancy's well-meaning boyfriend — in the
original 1984 movie. Freddy pulls Glen into
what may be Hell, then shoots his blood back
up through his mattress, soaking the bedroom
ceiling in a geyser of crimson Glen juice.
In later films, Freddy's homicidal tendencies
take a turn for the goofy and gimmicky.
There's a character who likes comic books
in Nightmare 5: The Dream Child, so Freddy
physically sucks him into a comic book and
cuts him up while he's two-dimensional.
There's a character who smokes weed in
Freddy's Dead, so Freddy turns into a
psychedelic hallucination and kills him that
way. Sometimes he takes himself seriously,
but other times, Freddy is basically
Willy Wonka, except a troupe of Oompa
Loompas don't appear to sing a judgmental
song after he destroys a young human life.
One of the most disturbing things
about Freddy is how he can morph and
manipulate his body whenever he feels
like it. It's a staple of the series.
For example, Freddy makes his arms grow
absurdly long right before he indulges
in his first onscreen taste of slaughter.
In the second film, he explodes out of a
young man's midsection, then heads across
the room to stab another hapless teen.
But Freddy doesn't get genuinely hyped about
shapeshifting until Nightmare 3: Dream Warriors.
He morphs his fingers into syringes to murder
a recovering addict, becomes a big ol' worm,
and he turns himself into a television set before
electrocuting a mentally ill girl to death.
Even in New Nightmare, Freddy puts Gene
Simmons to shame with his ever-growing tongue.
Stabbing and slashing might be Freddy's
go-to choice for a quick and easy notch
on his belt. But when it comes time to kill
someone in the weirdest manner possible,
this slasher never hesitates to change himself
into some of the most ridiculous stuff imaginable.
One of the creepiest things about Freddy
Krueger is that he's got his own theme song.
And the frightening tune makes
an appearance in every film.
Most of the time, it's a small group of little
kids singing it to keep time while they skip rope.
Since Freddy’s methods vary to wild extremes
depending on the characteristics of his victim,
Freddy doesn't have a signature catchphrase
because no single pun or one-liner would be
effective for the majority of his murdering. But
the wholesome image of little kids skipping rope
serves the same purpose, both on a visual and
sonic level. As we know from many other films,
little kids in horror movies are the
creepiest things ever. All they have
to do is walk into a shot, sing a spooky song,
and it'll make you pee your pants on the spot.
There aren't a ton of constants that stick
throughout Nightmare movies. But if you're a total
psycho who genuinely wants to see Freddy Krueger
come out on top, then the experience of watching
these films must make for a profoundly frustrating
experience. Why? Because Freddy always loses.
Freddy walks away with his fair share of
consolation prizes, no doubt. After his
inevitable vanquishing, he might jump out of
seemingly nowhere and snatch up someone's mom,
he might put his razor hand through a young
woman's torso, or he might wink at the camera
as Jason Voorhees carries his severed head
off-screen. He wins these sneaky, after-the-fact
victories that mainly serve to leave the door
open for a possible sequel. But that's only
after he comes up short in whatever his primary
goal happened to be during the particular story.
He can't win because one or more of his
prospective victims always manages to outsmart
and outmatch him. But if Freddy Krueger's purpose
is to kill a handful of people, face defeat,
then return in a couple of years when studio
executives decide it’s time for another movie,
maybe the concepts of winning and
losing don't concern him that much.
Perhaps Freddy Krueger is just a guy
with a job to do, like the rest of us.
The slasher subgenre frequently finds itself
accused of sameness and redundancy — and
rightly so. Plenty of slasher movies are exactly
the same. An invincible monster is introduced, and
one by one, it cuts down a roster of attractive
20-something actors playing high schoolers.
A sole-surviving protagonist vanquishes the
adversary and escapes, and then the movie ends.
However, filmmakers started taking risks
with Freddy as early as the first sequel.
A Nightmare on Elm Street 2: Freddy's Revenge
repurposes Robert Englund's signature villain
into a metaphor for repressed homosexuality. The
third movie, Dream Warriors, takes place in a
mental asylum for troubled youths. At one point,
Freddy turns into a giant worm version of himself
to eat a young Patricia Arquette. It's not as bold
as Freddy's Revenge, but it's definitely shocking.
The first three Nightmare films are all totally
distinct from each other. And the following three
movies are all too ridiculous to be predictable.
Freddy turns his victims into a supernatural
pizza in Nightmare on Elm Street 4: The Dream
Master. That's not even scary. It's just bonkers.
Things get especially wild with New Nightmare,
where director Wes Craven turns the metatextual
irony up to 11 by having Krueger be an actual
demon that exists outside the Nightmare movies.
"Love ya babe! We’ll do lunch”
In other words, Freddy Krueger doesn't repeat
himself. His movies might not all be great,
but at least he's never boring.